what's a call of duty game without a few
broken guns for nearly two decades the
series has had its share of
infamous overpowered or barely
functional weapons here's a look at some
of the most broken guns in the call of
duty series
an early arriver in the broken guns
category the desert eagle from the first
modern warfare
is one of the most iconic entries on the
list the sound
the look the jumpy animation and of
course
that damage damn boy the deagle deals 50
damage at
close range that sounds good but sort of
limiting right you would think so
considering it's only a semi-auto
handgun
but remember that in cod 4 semi-auto
guns had no fire cap
so you could spam all seven of your
shots in the blink of an eye
the deagle also had a surprisingly low
recoil despite its animation
if you could ignore that wobble you
could still hit your shots with
surprising accuracy
thanks to its super fast centering speed
also thanks to the og call of duty gods
the desert eagle had a headshot
multiplier of 1.4 damage
increasing that sweet sweet 2 shot kill
potential
all of this in one badass package that
offered zero attachments
because it would be a sin to silence
this
much like its older brother 2019's
modern warfare has
tons of overpowered weapons the only
difference is that these have been
patched a little more frequently
over the yearly call of duty releases a
great example being the snakeshot 357s
before the patch these were
after players unlocked the snake shot
ammo and began equipping two of them
it was a very rough few weeks for modern
warfare players in this department
we go by the book
bye book compilations began flooding the
internet of these two magnums destroying
players in both multiplayer as well as
warzone it got to a point where players
use these as their primary weapons
that's because the one shot kill range
of these was 5 meters
that was stock without any attachments
this damage range was dropped to 3.8
meters which sounds like it would help
fix the issue
but as you can see here it's still
pretty powerful
can't stop me
as previously discussed in our best guns
of call of duty video
the battle 27 was a broken fan favorite
it had high damage at close range with
seemingly no recoil
like other guns later in the black ops
series it also had a quirk
which was an increased fire rate over
time this quickly became the deadly
combo of choice for assault rifle users
with a call of duty community well
established at this point youtubers and
pro players clamored over this weapon's
deadliness
some called out for a nerf while others
wanted to keep the battle of duty as
is however less than a month after
launch the gun was nerfed and was given
severely increased recoil thanks to all
the jumping around in advanced warfare's
multiplayer
people moved on to other options with
that lower recoil we all crave
next up is the dragon off no matter what
call of duty game you're playing the
dragon off is simply a hit marker
machine
it might be fun to use if you're trying
to mix it up with a goofy class but if
you're going for kills
look elsewhere in a handful of other
games the dragon off is a serviceable
weapon
but in the call of duty world it's bad
at best
it's low damage mixed with high recoil
will have you losing gun fights to just
about
every other weapon in and out of its
class why it's in more than a dozen call
of duty titles is beyond me
the gun is even underwhelming to look at
it looks like someone stretched out an
ak-47
and made it worse in games like advanced
warfare and 2019's modern warfare just
about any other sniper rifle or marksman
rifle will get the job done better than
the dragon off ever could
maybe it's added into every call of duty
as a running joke
i don't know this one hurt coming off
the heels of modern warfare 2 i was
excited to try out the new lineup of
lmgs offered in black ops 1.
sadly the first one featured in the
custom class was the pathetic
hk21 this lmg suffers from the usual
fault of a weapon of its size
slow run speed dismal aim downsides time
but to make it worse the hk had the
jumpiest recoil i recall from that
entire game
other guns with high recoil veer left
right and up
predictable patterns right the hk21 does
all of the above to make matters worse
four of its five optional attachments
are scopes
scopes on a gun this slow and jumpy
scopes only make the experience
worse but for some players any scope
tops the unusually small iron sights
also if you choose a scope you're stuck
with a lousy 30 round magazine
is there a foregrip no is there a bipod
in the picture is there a reason to use
this no
way the only redeeming quality it sounds
cool i guess
on paper the hs10 looks like it would be
a fun addition it sounds cool
it has a unique design and it fits the
whole espionage theme of the first black
ops game
it's even teased as an alluring
classified weapon that can only be
unlocked after every other shotgun had
been unlocked first
when you do get your hands on it you'll
come to find that it is an incredibly
underwhelming shotgun even by shotgun
standards the hs10's range
is pathetic and to rub salt into that
wound you start with a max ammo of 4
bullets so prepare to hide a lot or lose
a lot
its only attachment is dual wielding
which strips you of the ability to aim
down sights
and aiming down sights is the only thing
that made it barely usable in the first
place
may i suggest the spas 12 instead
if you've played 2019's modern warfare
at all in the last year
you'll know the growl 556 launched in
season 2
and continually patched until season 4
the growl was an overpowered laser beam
especially in war zone with the right
attachments this thing became the acr
from modern warfare 2 with higher damage
the amount of people using damascus camo
on the grouse was ridiculous
this gun was worth grinding for and the
only thing that rained it in a bit was
infinity ward's
1.23 patch this massive update from june
2020
nerfed the grouse damage range on the
base barrel increased its recoil
and also dropped its damage range when
you use the popular arc angel
and nexus barrel attachments what
remains is still a very competitive gun
that is used often but has indeed lost
its luster
in a small memorable window of time this
gun paired with the mp5
completely overtook the warzone
experience
let's talk about modern warfare 2's
ump-45
aka the little engine that can and will
unlocked immediately in a default class
the ump does 40 damage up close and 35
at a distance
making it as little as a three shot kill
and with a devilish fire rate of 666
rounds per minute this could melt anyone
faster than even some shotguns
and if you're an absolute animal you can
even increase that to 845 rounds per
minute with rapid fire
as someone who avoids firing from the
hip take it from me when i tell you that
it's encouraged here
in fact if you don't like aiming down
sights good news you can use this gun
akimbo
they tried to reintroduce this gun back
into modern warfare with the striker 45
but it's okay in the sea of overpowered
weapons that is modern warfare 2 the ump
is not just an elite choice of smgs but
it's so good that it's broken
let's continue with the modern warfare
series only this time we'll be looking
at part 3
and the infamous fmg9s being a secondary
weapon you'd think this machine pistol
would be nothing to write home about
but no this collapsible nightmare was
another popular choice as a primary
weapon
and for good reason its 40 point damage
is paired with a destructive rate
of 1034 rounds per minute
i'll say that again 1034 rounds per
minute
making it the highest in the entire game
extended mags are probably the best
attachment seeing how it's a bullet hose
but you'll likely find everyone using
these at kimbo and spraying their heart
out just like they did in 2011. the fmg9
only takes as little as three shots to
kill someone
or two if you land headshots why the
g18s and
fmg9s are in modern warfare 3 is a weird
one besides the collapsible body they're
the same gun
style points i guess regardless if you
were near someone using the fmg9s turn
around and run
because you will be deleted
the model 1887s these guns were from a
time in call of duty some would call the
golden years
if you were like me you were curious
after getting killed by them millions of
times
you finally unlock a single model 1887
at level 67.
please what harm can i really do with
these you say as you reluctantly build a
class
the match starts and you're scared
shotguns don't have the best range
i should take cover you spot someone
with their back turn
now's your chance you waste the poor
fool and it feels like a door
unlocked your heart gets warm and you
realize why people are drawn to this
silly 100 year old gun
the 1887 was a mess its damage and range
were embarrassingly good
and that's only when you used one of
them without question
the best way to use the 1887 was going
akimbo
i still have very vivid memories of
getting blasted in the alleyways of
favela with these things
and you know what these memories grow
fonder the older i get
we need broken guns in call of duty
games even if for a while before the
inevitable patch
making this list took me down a fun
nostalgic road of call of duty's past
so please continue to share your
favorite broken guns in the comments
what i miss the 725s the intervention
the brekkie
i want to hear them all call of duty
black ops cold war is coming our way
soon
so be sure to subscribe to stick around
for full coverage and
ps5 gameplay thanks for watching
you